maintenant l'organisation mondiale de la
santé elle va envoyer des équipes
d'experts dans les pays limitrophes de
la guinée du liberia 2 des pays les plus
touchés par l'épidémie d'ebola pour
vérifier l'efficacité des mesures de
contrôle de l'infection
et puis un nouveau cas suspect a été
hospitalisé à madrid en espagne il était
à bord d'un avion arrivé du nigeria
alors sophie langlois vous êtes à
conakry en guinée où il ya fort fort à
faire pour convaincre les guinéens
d'aller se faire soigner
oui la sensibilisation est toujours des
clés pour freiner cette épidémie on a pu
constater ce matin avec une équipe de la
croix rousse qui étaient déployés dans
un quartier de la capitale pour cette
sensibilisation
on a pu voir à quel point la
méconnaissance est encore immense il ya
même des gens qui croient encore que le
bola n'existe pas c'est une invention de
politiciens pour leurs serveurs et
peut-être retarder les présidentielle
l'an prochain et surtout jeu qu'on voit
c'est une inquiétude par rapport aux
symptômes de l'ebola qui sont très
fréquents et si vous savez avoir la
fièvre la diarrhée
c'est très fréquent surtout dans la
saison des pluies comme on l'est entre
la barrière des symptômes très
semblables et comme au début de
l'épidémie ce taux de mortalité était
très aisée les gens ont l'impression on
part d'appeler pour dire on a fait
symptômes là bas sinon ces pressions qui
vont aller mourir à l'hôpital
donc il est encore très très bien encore
un gros travail à faire pour convaincre
les gens qui sont malades d'appeler à un
numéro qui a été créé pour eux
donnez-leur 5 tonnes ou si c'est jugé
nécessaire qu'on viendra les chercher et
on les amènera à l'hôpital puis vous
avez aussi assisté à un enterrement
oui parce que ça aussi c'est important
de le dire ça fait partie des moyens
pour lutter contre la contagion
au départ on en a beaucoup entendu
parler les gens cachés leur mort pour
être capable de les enterrer dignement
il ya eu aussi beaucoup de travail de
fait là pour convaincre les familles de
faire enterrer les dessins par les
équipes de la croix rouge qui le font de
façon sécuritaire
il sait ce qu'on a vu sa matin
effectivement c'est une grosse
concession de gros sont remis
pas pour ces gens qui sont très très
très religieux qui ont des rythmes à
respecter mais maintenant au lieu de les
enterrer loin des familles ont leur
terne est d'être présent à une saine
distance mais d'être là et de plus en
plus on voit que les canines un gentil
les leurs malades c'est pas ça qui sont
mort des mollahs ont appelé la parole
pour faire entériner malin sophie l'on
doit à merci beaucoup de témoigner pour
nous de ce qui se passe en conakry à
conakry en guinée
merci au revoir je vous en prie